[Applause]
[Music]
it's friday you should be happy don't
stop
happy friday my friday happy people what
a glorious show filled with glorious
things you know what makes me hot right
now other than my blue eyes and gorgeous
pecs
canadian truckers yeah in the era of
covid craziness they said screw this
madness and they stepped on the gas
this started with vaccine mandates but
for most here it's about a lot more well
over a thousand people lining the
trans-canada highway outside of winnipeg
in -30 wind chills protesting what they
call government overreach it all started
a couple days ago in delta bc truckers
protesting vaccine mandates at the
border
now as the convoy logs more kilometers
it's getting more support
kilometers
yeah canadian truckers
protested vaccine mandates placed on
their industry with a massive convoy
that might break the world record set by
democrats vacationing in florida
thank you for that laugh
according to organizers it's 70
kilometers long which is roughly five of
cats hair extensions tied together
actually it's 43.5 miles and that is
pretty amazing it's the best thing to
come from canada since moose
that's where they come from
canada
anyway the freedom convoy as it's called
left sunday from vancouver for ottawa
places that hockey fans inform me are
cities
to protest the mandates for cross-border
truckers took effect on january 15th
it's estimated that roughly 15 of
truckers in the country are not fully
vaccinated which is about 16 000 truck
drivers or 80 percent of the total
canadian population
true it's so sparsely populated the
social distance requirements is 600 feet
but i enjoy the convoy fact is if you
mess with the truckers you don't get
your stuff from my pillows to hockey
equipment beer clothing to 150 illegals
from guatemala it just takes too long by
dog sled
and it's absurd mandating vaccines for
people who spend more time alone than
cat on prom night
yeah
it's okay i know it's okay we all were
there except i had a blast meanwhile who
comes out against the truckers
ugh the canadian prime minister justin
trudeau the low-life skunk my apologies
to pepe lepew
here he is trashing the truckers the
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are uh
holding unacceptable uh views uh that
they're expressing
do not represent
the views of canadians following the
science
and stepping up to protect each other
is the best way to continue to ensure
our freedoms he's the pm more like a bm
this pile of human dung just said the
protesters are a small fringe minority
who are holding unacceptable views
so what are these unacceptable views you
jerk explain it to us since this fringe
helped keep your country going when you
couldn't
seriously he just crapped on people who
made sure canadian citizens like him got
their toilet paper their ginger ale the
cheese curds for their poutine or
whatever they eat in canada these days
during the pandemic
just like having a dad who was prime
minister working from home is a
privilege
most don't have these people worked
tirelessly until they were red in the
face as opposed to their pm who prefers
to only be in blackface
when the only thing black about him is
his heart if he was in alberta they'd
sell him as oil shale what an
embarrassing virtue signaling imposter
yes i wrote this while i was drinking
and those raspberry hard seltzers were
delivered by truckers so god bless him
so hooray to the canadian truckers or as
elon musk said in just three words
canadian truckers rule
and they do
but you know who else rules the danes
you might even say they're great
not the dogs the people of denmark or
the government of denmark they have a
government there i hear
unlike our country today anyway
yesterday denmark also became heroes by
announcing the end of the pandemic and
on what day did they choose you ask
yes i answer february 1st the date this
show picked as the end to the pandemic
yeah apparently they watch gutfeld in
between cobbling and smoking mackerel
how amazing is that according to
whatever i read
denmark is ending all its pandemic
measures and virus restrictions on the
last day of january that's martha
mccallum's birthday by the way i know i
hope she likes the present i got her
although i forgot to poke holes in the
box
[Laughter]
but their reasoning for ending their
restrictions the disease
like andrew cuomo no longer poses a
threat to society so they'll be
reclassifying the pandemic as an endemic
for more let's go to our denmark denmark
correspondent hans life in schnauz
greg are you stupid
do i look danish to you i'm not a danish
correspondent get your head out of your
ass
and i'm working leave me alone
working
so this easing of restrictions follows
other countries like the uk and ireland
as people find out that omicron is less
severe than the sentences handed down
for gun crime
where delta was charles manson omicron
is more like charles nelson riley
so they realize that no restriction is
going to stop the contagious but mild
strain omicron is like dana perino's dog
pictures it's everywhere
but you can handle it
and we don't need the government or neil
young telling us what to do
right now denmark a nation to 6 million
people has just 44 coveted 19 patients
in icu
and i'm willing to bet they're older
than stuart varney and britt hume
combined
stop it
so like listening
so like listening to the couple in the
next apartment having sex
it sounds to me like they know what
they're doing
so what about us what are we doing
february 1st is next week
when are we going to take the lead here
and bring this to an end since our
leaders won't like hollywood
screenwriters they suck at endings
so let's take inspiration from the
canadian truckers and the danish
cobblers and declare this thing over
once and for all and then get back to
normal life where we make fun of
canadians and danes instead of
complimenting them
period
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
she held trump make america great while
kicking ass at the department of state
former state department spokeswoman
morgan ortegas
his favorite feelings are her feelings
fox news contributor and washington
times opinion editor charlie hur
she's here for her insights and in case
i need something from a top shelf fox
and friends first co-host carly shimkas
and tgi fridays told her to come back on
monday foxy's contributor cat tip
charlie the truck drivers now i hope
this is a peaceful thing i don't want
anything to get out of hand but it's
really kind of inspirational to see
everybody going out there seeing this
long line i get the feeling that it's
the it's the people who are going to
decide when this thing is over what do
you think mr hurt
you know it's amazing uh at some point
it starts to you know as we're the more
we realize that the vaccines don't
actually prevent people from getting the
disease and apparently the masks don't
work which i think most normal people
realize from early on
you have these politicians who are
clinging
more to the the rules and the
regulations
than ever before and i think a lot of it
has to do with the fact that this has
never been about controlling the virus
this has been about control
from the beginning and these people like
justin trudeau just don't want to they
don't want to let go of power yeah i
will i will push back a little bit and
say that even though yeah obviously it
doesn't
the vaccines don't stop the spread that
is true it does help when you get the
disease okay that's fine yeah absolutely
then then then pedal it as that yes then
advertise it is that that's great but
but my concern about this is that these
people are doing the greatest damage to
real vaccines that really do prevent you
from getting polio or whatever by
calling this a vaccine it's not a
vaccine it does alleviate uh the
symptoms and that's a great way to sell
it yeah sell it as that well i knew if
there was a charlie charlie hurt vaccine
and i took it it probably wouldn't work
i would hope not yes
morgan um did you ever meet justin
trudeau uh oh um at maybe like the g20
or the g8 with president trump he walked
by like i i was you know just a staffer
so he's a small little man isn't he he's
smaller than me he's very spiritually
and morally yeah he's very much a soy
boy yeah he's a soy boy very good point
very good point was it was i too harsh
on him uh no listen no i don't think so
i think you know he has people in his
country that are expressing a view that
he says is unacceptable um and he's
supposed to be the leader of everybody
there yeah and listen what i'm most
impressed about with these truckers i
think you said that it was like below 30
degrees when they were if it was below
30 you could have martial law from the
chinese communist party and i wouldn't
leave my apartment right like there's no
way i'd be like okay just keep the heat
on uh so i'm impressed by them because i
would not get out and protest but how
bad is it in canada that that's you know
what you got to do but you're seeing it
er carly you're seeing it in every
country's where is denmark by the way
it's in europe it's in europe thank god
i knew that yeah it is your imagination
yeah i don't want to pull like a
jeopardy don't ask me any more questions
yes
if you care about me at all yes yes no
but denmark it's a tiny country filled
with denmarkians i think that's what
they're called
uh they're they're a tropical bunch
uh just uh they have their own dialect
and uh uh and judge jeanine is the
president yeah yes yes they worship i
guess a tv they found a tv on an island
and they saw judge jeanine and they just
thought it was a god
they thought it was a god and now they
worship the the the uh
yeah the spirit of this amazing creature
that comes from the metal box without a
doubt i don't even know what i'm asking
well first of i love canadian truckers
too manly profession very attractive and
then um
justin trudeau is like
he's like the classic movie bad guy that
seems like super innocent and then 15
minutes in you realize that he's an
authoritarian dictator right um and you
know the fact that he said that this is
a fringe group of people with an
unacceptable view is the most thought
police thing i have ever heard in my
life yeah and then we're talking about
truck drivers which is a profession that
is just forced isolation yeah you don't
have a co-worker you're not spreading
covey to anybody yes so i don't i don't
understand why he's pinpointing this
group of people he should just say okay
you know what you guys helped us through
the pandemic thank you for your service
continue on with your life yeah yeah i
mean i always say thank you for your
service to truck drivers
yeah you know the fundamentals didn't
provide a very good service and you know
what you want to you want to screw with
the supply chain exactly just i mean
just totally empty you know what he is
he's the maitre d
he actually looks like a maitre d and
he's trying to cook the meal and he
should say no you're just for a friend
you're just for front of the house
justin you can hit on the bartenders
that's all you're allowed to do kat you
bro this is interesting what covete has
done
teachers are now the record baits and
truck drivers are now the heroes yeah is
that incredible yeah and i want to move
to denmark
yeah and i don't let you i don't know no
probably not i don't know anything about
it everything you could have said it's
true as far as i know yes uh because you
know they're like pandemics over and
we're not even talking about that we're
not even talking about what would that
take to get there yes we're not saying
what what numbers what metric would be
okay to get rid of these restrictions
what we're doing is we have that tweet
actually i want to show the laurie
lightfoot oh fantastic so if i don't
this is what we're doing yeah he's
tweeting this saying if you get vast
this stack can be yours that's money
yeah if if if you get vaxxed you can
have this 826
of cash that i have arranged on my rug
that's what we're doing i don't want to
live here anymore i wonder how many
people were shot in chicago while she
was arranging the money in the cash yeah
i'm sure she wasn't the only one
arranging it but god that is just
idiotic it is real yeah or that she does
look like she was up all night doing it
but then she always looks like she's up
all day
anyway i said february 1st
it's coming true
i might be off a few days but
psychologically this is the bullseye i
think i think you can feel it in your
bones i don't know maybe
you know like california will be the
caboose on this one i think hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else